big morning for you dare I say you
crushed it how'd you do it tell me what
are you doing inside this company
because it seems like the rest of
Corporate America is hurting well I'm
glad you're here in our Times Square
store and knew the brand is alive and
vibrant I couldn't be happier for our
employees for our customers and our
shareholders and you're right we crushed
it
we added 8.3 million customers in 2015
again we had a hundred and eight percent
of all the post paid phone growth in the
industry let me give you an idea what
that means in 2015
t-mobile added 3.5 million postpaid
phone subscribers AT&T Verizon and
Sprint any guess together - two hundred
and sixty-nine thousand but are you
making money doing it because you
started this price war a couple years
ago with the uncarrier program can be so
it's great for consumers coming in it's
great for consumers but how about you
and I'm glad you're here today is the
biggest the reason I'm behaving today is
it's very important to get across this
point the model is working what does
that mean that subscriber growth is
leading to revenue growth service
revenue is up eleven point seven percent
year-over-year to EBIT a growth we grew
even a 32.2% an adjusted free cash flow
in q4 was up 800 percent year-over-year
so the model is working and we're doing
it by solving customer pain point sounds
cliche but the uncarrier stands for
solving customer pain points and fixing
what was a stupid broken arrogant
industry for the most important thing in
most people's lives you're also doing
things in an unconventional way binge on
video streaming service has a lot of
people talking about net neutrality
issues are you gonna have to change the
way you're planning on rolling this or
no no we very care we are Pro net
neutrality and we very carefully
described it nav in John I'm not
everybody knows what it is but let me
give you the where we're headed all
content is going to the Internet all
Internet is going mobile the
fastest-growing use of data services on
your devices video and the pain point is
overages and over buying so we created
binge
which has been highly highly successful
why is it Pro net neutrality anybody can
come any provider any customer most
importantly completely customer choice
pound to six for pound you can turn it
on you can turn it off
very easily with content agnostic right
so it's it's it's clearly right in the
sweet spot of pro net neutrality seeing
that subscriber growth is growing and
where do you think it's gonna grow next
year we gave guidance of two point four
to three point four you know branded
what can you tell us about the US
economy and the consumer because so many
people are saying we're in a massive
slowdown but I don't see it here okay do
you know that this quarter was the
eleventh quarter in a row that we added
more than a million customers so there's
a couple things I would say what not
that we are we can survive in any
economy because again good economy bad
economy people are going to participate
in wireless services maybe even more so
in a rough economy because you know
you're more conscious of what a
significant part of your money is I see
a vibrant economy I mean I see people
especially on smartphones and on
wireless services participating at a
rate greater than ever before then how
did you make sense of your stop getting
hit so hard in January hit worse than
the rest of the market well two things
one is our stock is up forty five
percent last year second is where a
consensus long which is a new
environment for us we are one of the
most recommended stocks to hold but
right now in 2016 the beginning I would
call it hedge fund D risking so people
are selling what they can not what they
want to but if you look at the 12-month
targets for us I think the average
12-month price target for us talk is
about forty six so I feel pretty good we
got 15 seconds you know what I want 5g
how are you getting from four to five G
well first of all the the imminent 5g
that some of our competitors said is
coming is gonna be delayed it's not
really here yet but I can trust you when
it it's available in all its benefits
you're going to get there we have